good morning John this week I woke up in
New York City and my hair looked like
this and then I went outside and it
looked like this and then I went back
inside and filmed an episode of the
financial diet which looked like this
you can watch it at youtube.com slash
the financial diet and then I saw you
and you looked like this and then Sarah
took us around to a bunch of amazing art
galleries in Chelsea and they looked
like this and this and this and I felt
very lucky that you are married to
someone who understands art because even
as a person who doesn't really think
very much about art I still really
appreciate it and it's wonderful to look
at amazing art but it is difficult to
find it or if you do find it to feel
like you belong in those spaces with
their giant white walls and terrifying
price lists at one point I went into a
banana republic and I got a shirt for
the thing that we're doing tonight and I
didn't take any footage of that but I
wanted to mention it because of how much
I appreciated the quiet assertiveness of
the young man who helped me pick out my
outfit because I would have been totally
lost without him when I'm in New York I
am for some reason more than anywhere
else amazed by the reality that it all
somehow works that all of the people
from the cab drivers to the garbage
collectors to the guide the Banana
Republic who helps fools like me look
presentable to the people pruning and
decorating the Christmas tree at
Rockefeller Center all come together to
make this thing function I mean New York
City is full of amazing and beautiful
things but in a lot of ways the most
amazing thing I saw today was this not
because I have tremendous brand affinity
for Preta mache which to be clear I'd
totally do but because food is
complicated so many ingredients edible
for such a short time after their
creation and yet there's always food it
might cost more than in the rest of the
world but it's always there
and I'm not amazed at how good it is or
how good it tastes but simply at the
logistics how does it happen how do we
feed and water all these people
sometimes it seems like everything is
broken and nothing works at all but when
things work we don't tend to notice
there's nothing quite like knowing as I
have my whole life that there will be
food at the corner store I don't spend
enough time being grateful for that and
not just grateful that I can always get
food but grateful that so many people
come together and work hard to make sure
that all of the people in New York City
can continue eating and drinking and
everything can continue to function
that's not something that just happens
that's something that people do John
I'll see you tonight